what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and at san diego comic
con that happened over the weekend we
obviously got some major reveals when it
comes to phase five and phase six but
maybe something you don't know is that
they actually gave us trailers and
footage for ant-man and the wasp quantum
mania and for guardians of the galaxy
vol 3. now unfortunately these trailers
were not shown to the public because
they were not completely finished in
fact james gunn even replied to people
on twitter that wanted to see the
trailer stating that the visual effects
just were not done for the trailer yet
so they didn't want to show it to the
entire world which is completely
understandable because when the trailer
for she-hulk first came out people tore
that thing apart over the visual effects
but the great news is that the trailer
is done they just have to polish it up a
little bit which means we should be
getting it relatively soon of course the
ant-man and the wasp trailer is going to
come beforehand where we'll get our
first look at king the conqueror but in
the meantime we have a full description
of what they showed for the guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 trailer and we're gonna
go over all the details and break it
down now i'll go over two different
accounts of trailer descriptions one has
a little bit of info but the other is
pretty detailed so let's go over both
the first one comes from gizmodo and
here's their description of the
guardians 3 trailer they say by the time
of the third movie the ravangers are now
being led by gamora who we see having a
fun banter-laden reunion with peter
quill after their complicated
relationship troubles in avengers
infinity war and avengers end game as
peter tries to get gamora to remember
him in the new footage screen to fans
set of course to flaming ellipses do you
realize of course james gunn always
picks great music we see a glimpse of a
young baby rocket raccoon in flashbacks
which will play a major role in
guardians vol 3 as we explore his
origins as the test subject of a cruel
experimentation on the planet half world
also featured in the footage was cosmo
the psychic russian dog and in the
comics security chief of the space
station nowhere played by borat maria
baklava and she actually came out with
the guardian's cast at the hall h panel
and they officially did announce this so
that's really exciting cosmo was going
to be a part of the guardians of the
galaxy but let's continue on with what
they saw during the trailer they say
plus an all-gold all-dazzling glimpse at
adam warlock played by will poulter and
a glimpse of the high evolutionary a
powerful being who now thanks to the mcu
is actually the person who transformed
the scarlet witch and her brother
quicksilver into super-powered beings
leading them to believe that they were
the mutant children of magneto in the
comics now this did happen in the comics
the high evolutionary is actually the
person who experimented on quicksilver
and the scarlet witch and what's
interesting is that he actually
experimented on them at windagor
mountain and we saw one de gore mountain
in doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness so i'm guessing that there is
still somewhat of a connection there now
at one point in time there was a comic
storyline that said magneto was indeed
the biological father of the scarlet
witch in quicksilver however the comics
would go on to eventually change this
again so as far as what story they're
going to show in the mcu i'm really
hoping that magneto is the true
biological father of the scarlet witch
in quicksilver but we'll have to wait
and see on that back to the trailer the
description continues and says several
members of the guardians rocket and
groot were absent they believe jump out
of a ship onto what looks like a larger
alien planet they're each wearing
brightly colored suits each one
different blue green red orange and
yellow they're obviously going on a
mission of some sort and it's here where
peter tries to talk to gamora about
their past he asks if she might be
willing to open herself up and she says
i don't think so quinn in which he
replies quill it's quill at which point
mantis tells peter that they're on an
open channel and everyone can hear it
then shows peter and the rest of the
guardians very embarrassed for peter the
final parts of the trailer seem to be a
bunch of scenes shown pretty quickly it
says that it shows the guardians in what
looks like them opening up a store it
shows the evil monster from the
beginning of guardians 2 it shows peter
and the team getting off on what looks
like an earth neighborhood and at the
end it shows the group all walking in
slow motion groot now much thicker and
more muscular no rocket and gamora
walking in the background now before we
break it all down let's go over this
other trailer description from
comicbook.com it's much shorter but is a
little bit different it says guardians 3
footage sees the guardians captured by
ravangers and nebula reveals that they
have an appointment with gamora peter
quill is caught all the way off guard
peter reflects on their time together
you were everything to me he said i
thought you were gone but you're here
and i miss you gamora tells him that
person was not her we get our first look
at adam warlock we see a grown groot
fighting back to back with quill the
high evolutionary shows up the guardians
float on a space planet gamora caps the
trailer by calling quill by the wrong
name and turning him down the guardians
joke on quill for talking to her so
intimately on an open communication line
and they've been listening all along it
ends with mantis asking what we know
about rocket a shot of a very young
rocket raccoon takes the screen much of
the trailer was set to do you realize by
flaming lips so the first thing that you
have to know about this trailer
obviously is what happened during
avengers infinity war and what happened
during avengers end game in avengers
infinity war thanos killed the gamora
that loved peter and that peter loved
then of course in avengers in-game
thanos and gamora and nebula from a
different timeline went into our
avengers main timeline in which gamora
then turned good but then kind of ran
off and did her own thing not before she
managed to kick quill in the nuts of
course showing that she really was not
the same gamora that peter knew and the
description of this trailer makes that
very very apparent the gamora that is
now in our main timeline is not the old
gamora the old gamora is truly dead but
the new one seems to be in charge of the
ravagers now and the guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 post-credits scene teased
us with a new group of ravangers
sylvester stallone being one of them so
that's definitely going to be really
really cool to see now it seems like for
whatever reason gamora does decide to go
with the guardians of the galaxy because
it seems like she is with them the rest
of the trailer perhaps she goes because
of nebula the two of them did have a
bonding moment an avengers end game
where nebula says we eventually do
become sisters so perhaps it's nebula
and the desire for sisterhood that
convinces gamora to go with them now the
rest of the important parts of the
trailer though seem to focus on the high
evolutionary and the story around him
and rocket raccoon who is one of his
experiments in the comics the high
evolutionary started off by doing
experiments on animals trying to turn
them to basically humanoid forms of
themselves still animals but functioning
with human intellect basically now of
course people thought this was extremely
weird and the high evolutionary ended up
leaving to another planet which he
called counter-earth where he planned to
make it a paradise it was an exact copy
of earth based on the other side of the
sun but it became corrupted now in this
trailer they call this half world which
is basically counter earth and it's on
half earth that we see a glimpse of a
young baby rocker raccoon in the
flashbacks now we already know but in
the movie it will be revealed that
rocker raccoon is one of the test
subjects of the high evolutionary that
is what the high evolutionary does he
experiments on animals and turns them
into somewhat humanoid forms and rocket
raccoon in previous films has even said
well i didn't ask to get made so this is
really going to dive deep into the
origin story of how rocket raccoon came
to be who exactly he is now of course
the other big thing in the trailer is
the first look at adam warlock and
according to some descriptions and some
leaked images that i have seen adam
warlock still has a place on his head
for the soul stone adam warlock is
widely known for having the soul stone
on his head but of course with thanos
destroying all of the infinity stones
people were wondering well what exactly
is adam warlock going to look like will
he have a stone on his head or not and
while it doesn't exactly look like a
stone you can definitely tell there is
something there perhaps meant to house
the soul stone or an infinity stone in
general to give him power now based off
of all of the trailer descriptions they
only show adam warlock for a brief time
but we do get a good look at the high
evolutionary and we did get a great look
at him at san diego comic con and like i
have been talking about on the channel
for a long time it is confirmed that
chukwudi a woody will be playing the
high evolutionary and that's it for the
teaser remember it's just a teaser not a
full on trailer but it still seems like
they showed a lot now remember the
ant-man trailer is probably first
followed up by the guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 trailer but the good news
is that it is done so in the meantime
while we wait let me know what you think
about this footage description in the
comments down below and what would you
like to see from guardians 3. don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all things
mcu for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you